et pour commencer un chiffre le chiffre
de cette édition 3 3 comme le nombre de
projets de loi présentés ce matin
mercredi 24 avril par le gouvernement à
l'issue du conseil des ministres
trois projets de loi afin de restaurer
la confiance dans la vie politique une
opération mains propres en quelque sorte
la deux textes sont consacrés à la
transparence de la vie publique un autre
à la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
examen par le parlement prévue avant l
été avant de rentrer un petit peu dans
les détails jean luc trotignon avec
anticorps justement vous vous battez
pour cette moralisation de la vie
politique
toutes ces mesures qui ont été annoncées
le fait que le gouvernement se penche
sur cette question même si c'est après
laffaire cahuzac
ça va dans le bon sens bah oui dans ça
va dans le bon sens avec des choses qui
pourraient être mieux qu'il va y avoir
toute façon pas ça j'aimerais parlement
avec le nombre d'amendements qu'ils
aient qui peuvent être proposées
donc on attend de voir il ya des choses
qui précise assez précises maintenant
c'est ce que nous a dit qu on n'a pas
attendu la sphère qui a usé pour
réclamer tout ce genre de choses
notamment sur les conflits d'intérêts ça
semble pas aller assez loin pour nous
mais à d'autres choses qui avancent dans
dans le bon sens et notamment pour nous
mêmes il ya deux points qui concernent
directement les associations
anticorruption habilité qui qui pourront
saisir la haute autorité de la
transparence de la vie publique un
cessez le nom de cette nouvelle instance
qui devrait voir le jour justement avant
de détailler un petit peu tout ça est de
voir votre point de vue pour anticorps
philippe brillault et l'ump cette
décision du gouvernement socialiste de
se pencher sur cette moralisation de la
vie politique
c'est le complément de la transparence
de la vie politique la transparence plus
de transparence moralisation également
haute autorité de la transparence de la
vie publique c'est le nom de la nouvelle
instance
est ce que c'est une instance que vous
accueillez
plutôt de manière sympathique vous êtes
curieux de blessure ce que je pense qu'à
une continuité au gouvernement c'est
qu'après une transparence de politique
on a une transparence pour la vie
publique donc c'est quand même
intéressant alors je suis face à anticor
en tant que médecin moi je suis tout à
fait favorable aux anticorps qui luttent
contre les antigènes c'est à dire contre
tout ce qui peut polluer la vie
politique et la vie publique et avec une
ancienneté de 20 ans de mer je peux vous
dire que j'en ai vu beaucoup et qu' il
ya des règles à respecter on en parlera
sûrement alors la mission de cette
nouvelle instance que nous évoquions
l'instant le budget les moyens ne sont
pas encore précisés mais en tout cas
elle disposera de services fiscaux alors
un pouvoir d'injonction également et
puis elle pourra être saisi par le
premier ministre par les présidents de
l'assemblée nationale du sénat ainsi que
par les associations agréées c'est là
que je me tourne à nouveau vers vous
vers anticorps vous pourrez saisir cette
haute autorité en cas de doute sur des
déclarations de patrimoine des nues par
exemple tout à fait alors son sommet
seule entité delà de la société civile
qui pourront si c'est voter à intervenir
bon les associations agréées anti
corruption on verra ce que c'est mais
enfin en france y en a surtout 3 dont la
nôtre il est vraisemblable qu'on recevra
commence à beaucoup d alerte de citoyens
qui nous diront on en a reçus mais là il
n'y avait pas de conséquence pénale
quand les sénateurs il ya quelques mois
ont eu à faire une déclaration
d'intérêts sur le site du sénat
on nous a signalé pas mal de
déclarations d'intérêt qu'ils étaient
pas complète
donc là je pense qu'on sera sans doute
alerté pour puisqu'on aura la
possibilité nous de transmettre sein à
cette haute autorité la transparence de
la république sera composée de six
magistrats cour de cassation cour des
comptes conseil d'état et président
nommé en conseil des ministres après
avis du parlement
il ya cette question est derrière 2
ou non faut-il rendre public ou non ce
patrimoine des élus parce qu'il ya des
déclarations forcément mais ensuite
faut-il les rendre public vous allez
nous donner votre point de vu échanger
sur ce sujet après ce micro trottoir
quand vous pensez vous nous avons posé
la question à quelques citoyens parce
qu'on y déclare vraiment ce qu'on veut
moi quand j'ai vu comme déclaration de
voitures de plus de dix ans de la part
d'un ministre
le scooter de la part de la de
porte-parole du gouvernement
je me dis qu'il ne faut pas rigoler moi
l'important c'est que franchement qu'on
est ce qu on veut ici quoi c'est tout
après ce qu'il a gagné voilà il faut
faut aussi être réaliste il a travaillé
aussi en 30 ans donc je ne sais pas
c'est important parce que c'est quand
même quelque chose que ce moment là plus
ou moins envie de savoir avec en général
c'était grosso au départ j'aurais dit
oui et puis en fait quand je vois tout
ce qui est dévoilé
j'ai pas envie de le savoir parce que
parce qu'ils se foutent de nous je pense
que c'est une bonne idée os la
transparence quant à la continuité
en fait je peux vraiment d'avis sur la
question je joue avouer que façon ça ne
semble pas vraiment réel au pourquoi pas
mais ça sera plus de la curiosité
qu'autre chose les avis sont partagés
sur la question sur le fait de rendre ou
non publics le patrimoine des différents
élus et là on parle bien de tous les
élus et pas uniquement des ministres
comme ça a été le cas il ya quelques
jours quelques semaines je vais juste
vous préciser ce qui a été dit ce matin
à l'issue du conseil des ministres
les déclarations de patrimoine et
d'intérêt est des membres du
gouvernement des parlementaires
nationaux des principaux responsables
exécutifs locaux seront rendus public
selon les modalités qui seront précisées
par décret en conseil d'état le texte
n'est pas tout à fait arrêtée encore on
ne sait pas si ce sera finalement
obligatoire ce sera un tirage au sort
autres en tout cas quel est votre point
de vue pour monsieur brioches pour lui
indiquer que pour les mères c'est vrai
pas des communes partir de 30 mille
habitants moi je trouve que ce devrait
être à partir de un habitant moi je dis
qu'il ya deux choses il ya les
ressources et le patrimoine
le patrimoine moi je le dis
officiellement je suis soumis à isf
donc on sait la base minimum de mai de
mon capital et je suis assujetti au
contrôle des services fiscaux
la problématique sur le patrimoine c'est
quand vous ne déclarez pas relief est
donc là il faut combler ce vide pour un
élu qui ne déclarent pas lisf de façon à
être certain que son patrimoine est bien
conforme et donc ça c'est la première
donnée et puis enfilait les ressources
mois les ressources il faut tout
simplement afficher clairement avec quoi
nous vivons feuilles de paye
indemnisation retraite ou donc voilà je
crois qu'il ya dans ce cas il faut le
rendre public
oui tout le monde puisse y avoir accès à
savoir ce que gagnent en mer par exemple
en revanche sur le patrimoine qui est
qui a pu être obtenue au fur et à mesure
des années je suis content je suis
contre dire ce que je j'ai je pense
qu'ils les services fiscaux et
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit monsieur qui
peuvent contrôler ceci parce que moi je
vous dis qu'effectivement je suis à
l'iesf vous imaginez bien que nous
sommes contrôlés en permanence et c'est
pas parce qu'on va mettre tout cela en
place qu'il n'y aura pas éventuellement
lorsque quelqu'un a la volonté de
tricher
enfin quand je vois là qu'on a mis en
place une commission spéciale avec
monsieur jospin qui s'appelle la
rénovation et de déontologie de la vie
publique
on s'interroge quand on voit les noms
qui sont dedans enfin venir si on veut
pas de la transparence
allons jusqu'au bout je veux dire
monsieur jospin je crois une retraite à
sa demande d'indemnités et je vois que
là il va être rémunérée à concurrence de
122 mille euros alors ya une
transparence c'est qu'on le sait mais
est-ce que tout ceci est bien dans le
cadre de ce qu'attendent les français
moi je dis aujourd'hui c'est l'honnêteté
des élus qui est important il faut
trouver tous les moyens qui garantissent
les électeurs de cette honnêteté
alors nous sur la transparence ont pensé
c'est un volet uniquement on pense qu'il
est indispensable qu'ils aiment
déclaration du patrimoine en début de
mandat est en fin de mandat
tout simplement pour que les citoyens
puissent savoir s'il y avait eu un
enrichissement anormal pendant le mandat
mais ça n'est rien s'il n'y a pas un
organisme de contrôle
et s'il n'ya pas notamment des moyens
d'investigation pour
pour cet organisme de contrôle
effectivement cette nouvelle haute
autorité aura un pouvoir d'injonction et
pour exiger du fisc les renseignements à
leur tête à l'heure actuelle c'est pas
possible la commission pour la
transparence de la vie politique ne
pouvait pas le faire et le problème des
fraudes fiscales qui sont découvertes
c'est que seul ministère de l'économie
des finances pouvaient déposer plainte
ou ça s'arrange et dans le secret d'un
cabinet d'un bureau pas loin du ministre
pour mes gosses y est la fraude comment
baisser la faune la payer l'avocat des
compétences aux services fiscaux
justement de façon spécifique pour les
élus ça c'est celle de modalités ça
revient au même
on a des professionnels comme qui sont
louis mais ça revient bien de toute
façon le pouvoir d'injonction vis à vis
du fisc ce sera pour avoir les documents
préparés par le fisc donc ça vient un
peu promesse que les citoyens doivent
avoir accès assez de toutes ces
déclarations parce que ça donne à
oublier noir sur blanc à m
ça représente par exemple en prochaines
élections voilà il faut publier son
patrimoine
à mon avis on les élus doivent rendre
compte aux citoyens de début de mandat
fin de mandat pour les intermédiaires
pas forcément cela les modalités vont
être définis par le conseil d'état la
difficulté effectivement c'est que pour
le moi si je suis élu j'ai choisi
d'avoir un mandat public donc d'être un
homme public mais ma femme mes enfants
n'ont pas choisi donc la difficulté
c'est de protéger la vie privée de la
famille et enfin voit par exemple un
adjoint qui est responsable de la
commission d'appel d'offres est ce que
dans votre esprit
il est important que l'on ait ses
références patrimoniale moi je pense que
oui on devait resserrer le mandat oui
mais ça veut dire que toute personne qui
a une interférence avec je dirais les
finances publiques sachant que nous ne
vont pas de carnet de chèques par carte
bleue
mais tout ce qui est appel donne tout ce
qu'elle obéit à des principes quand on
en appel d'offres on reçoit personnes on
va pas casser la croûte on va pas des
matchs de foot on va pas tout cela j'ai
il ya des règles minimum sur ces
éléments et je pense que tous les élus
pas que le maire tous ceux qui ont une
délégation doivent être dans ses règles
d'obligations ya pas que le veau qui est
maire voulait leur gestion à ça
justement bien conscient de votre
conseil municipal
reveillez ce que font vos liens dans
adjoint oui bien sûr parce que j'en ai
la solidarité si j'ai deux personnes
derrière ma voiture qui n'aide pas la
ceinture de sécurité
c'est bien chauffeur qui en est
responsable et bien dans un conseil
municipal
moi je suis responsable de tout ce
qu'ils n'ont pas mis leur ceinture de
sécurité au niveau fiscal et au niveau
des ppte et il y aura des sanctions
aussi qu'ils seront plus importantes ça
fait partie de l'ensemble des mesures
des projets en tout cas puisque ce sera
ensuite débattu à l'assemblée qui ont
été présentés ce matin trois ans
d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros d'amendé
pour ceux qui ne joueraient pas le jeu
sur les différentes déclarations pour
les ministres ce sera 5 ans et 75000
euros d'amendé
là aussi les sanctions seront assez
forts et le renforcement pour les
fraudes fiscales se passe à sept ans de
prison
avec notamment un classement plus
d'infos aggravé fraude fiscale où on
rajoute le recours à des comptes
bancaires à l'étranger notamment
c'est assez sévère ben c'est assez
dissuasif c'est vrai que la justice a
tendance à aller au bout au fond d'eux
des peines possibles c'est très rare
mais c'est quand même assez dissuasif
donc et pour les tout nouveaux ministre
il y aura la haute autorité en question
de la transparence dans les publics qui
étudiera patrimoine de est revenue de ce
ministre là pour éviter les cas comme
jérôme cahuzac
est ce qu'on peut penser que ça va
refroidir des candidatures est ce qu'il
ya des gens qui vont se dire en bas dans
ces conditions je me présente pas là-bas
peut-être que monsieur cahuzac se serait
dit je n'accepte pas mon poste dominique
rocher pas sûr parce que pour mentir
devant une caméra de la même façon je
suis pas certain moi je crois que ce qui
me paraît important c'est que les
services fiscaux et les capacités et les
moyens de garantir la population de
l'honnêteté des élus moi je crois que ça
ça me paraît très important et qu'on
règle les problèmes de paradis fiscaux
de fiscalité parce que si vous avez
votre patrimoine en société pan société
en nom propre ou autre on sait comment
tout ça ça se passe les divorces enfin
bon je dirais que il faut aller loin moi
je pense que il faut en urgence met des
garanties pour les français par rapport
à ce que nous avons vécu il faut pas
qu'on aille trop loin
si c'est pour afficher tout son
patrimoine je pense que là il ya un
voyeurisme qui me paraît même négatif
pour la transparence politique
sur les mobilités aussi deux choses des
points de vue sur les numéros prévus ce
matin la création d'une police fiscale
justement qui agira avec le nouveau
parquet contre nationale contre la
corruption et puis le côté voyeurisme on
est quand même en europe il ya 27 pays
qui sur 27 pays a que deux pays qui sont
aussi secret sur les patrimoines et les
revenus des élus ce qui c'est la france
et la slovénie
bon elle dans les autres pays comme ce
qu'ils font au maximum les pays
scandinaves par exemple on ne peut pas
dire que ce sont des pays de voyeurisme
ça fonctionne quand même s'il manquera
ci fonctionne aussi sur l'éligibilité je
voulais avoir votre point de vue aussi
assez rapidement alors il propose ce le
gouvernement ni l'humilité définitive
pour les élus fraudeurs ou qui en cas
d'infraction qui portent atteinte à la
morale c'est une solution antivirale e
mail voilà le nom parce que le conseil
constitutionnel s'est déjà prononcée en
disant qu'il fallait une
individualisation des peines et qu'on
peut pas appliquer systématiquement à
tout le monde la même peine il faut que
le juge puisse pouvoir juger en
conscience mais il ya une solution qu'on
va pas s'gêner de leur rappeler leur
proposer ces deux maîtres comme
nouvelles conditions d'éligibilité le
fait d'avoir un casier judiciaire vierge
comme
pour les fonctionnaires inéligible quand
on m'a fait une faute ça me paraît
légitime à porter la faute de précision
et bien tout enrichissement personnel à
partir d'un mandat doit être sanctionné
sans réserve et l'éligibilité doit être
liée après c'est le problème des
corruption passive lorsqu'il ya un an
après c'est aux juges
effectivement d'appliquer mais lorsque
vous avez un acte volontaire
d'enrichissement personnel à partir des
compétences de son mandat c'est une
sanction sans réserve les personnels ou
pour son parti pour ses proches bien dit
c'est ce que j'appelle personnel
monsieur pardonnez moi mais je veux dire
bon on peut rencontrer certains cas
difficiles dans le cas des collectivités
qui sait qu'ils sont à part moi je dit
aujourd'hui oui tout enrichissement
personnel pour soi ou pour ses proches
doit été sanctionnés sans réserve un
sujet qui ne figurait pas dans les
différents projets de loi qui n'a pas
été très très clair c'est la fameuse
liste noire des métiers interdit aux
parlementaires alors il n'ya pas de
député de sénateur sur ce plateau mais
j'aimerais tout de même pour conclure
sur ce dossier de cette moralisation de
la vie politique pure et rendre public
justement tous et toutes ces affaires
tous ces dossiers on parlait donc de
cumul le fait d'être avocat d'affaires
journalistes voire consultant également
ça aurait été incompatible avec le fait
d'être député ou sénateur aujourd'hui on
n'en parle plus vraiment on parle elle
seulement des mentions de conseil les
activités dans les entreprises privées
en lien avec l'état aussi
là ça ne va pas assez loin il aurait
fallu interdire clairement certains
certaines fonctions certaines
professions avec le fait d'être députés
les sénateurs
oui pour nous il a ça recule pas ce qui
avait pu être annoncé les avocats
pourront continuer à être avocat sauf
s'ils sont si donne des conseils si son
conseil voilà ça ils pourront pas
exercer c'est la seule chose qui
apparaît être interdite pour l'instant
nous on pense que c'est ça nécessite
d'aller plus loin malheureusement c'est
les députés eux mêmes qui vont voter
leurs propres limites
donc on peut s'inquiéter pour faut faire
attention à pas couper la société civile
de la capacité d'avoir une action
politique
je crois que ça me paraît très important
je pense qu'il faut aussi que la loi
protège ceux qui peuvent avoir un mandat
de trois ou quatre ans qu'ils arrêtent
leur métier et qui trois quatre ans
après ne sont plus élus donc il faut
aller bien au delà de cette loi c'est
dire que si on supprime certains métiers
il faut que l'on garantisse aussi la
sécurité de l'arrêt de travail
oui absolument et nous on propose
d'ailleurs que soient liés il faut que
ce soit lille il ya deux ans deux
mandats maximum consécutifs comme ça ça
veut dire qu'on fait pas ça toute sa vie
comme un professionnel non plus
parlementaire et que pendant dix ans oui
si on peut faire une parenthèse et nous
servir l'intérêt général sans faire
exercer sa profession et confort
effectivement il faut des garanties pour
voir la reprendre un médecin vous n'êtes
pas content non sauf si vous entend
mener comme conseil avec les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
voilà je représente le département des
yvelines halal agences régionales de
santé
on m'a de faire remplir des feuilles ou
jeu garantit l'absence d'intérêts
croisés entre mes activités personnelles
est ce que je décide au niveau de la rs
ce qui me paraît légitime
oui mais qui contrôlait ce qu'il ya si
ça ne me reconnais pas dans les clous
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre
déclaration
moi j'ai déclaré après qu'est-ce que
commencer traité je ne sais pas c'est
pour ça qu'il ya un mois je pense que
c'est plus la façon de traiter les
contrôles qui me paraît importante de
fer voilà donc attention les moyens
attention à une loi rapide qui va
peut-être trop long trop vite et pas
assez loin
voilà et ce sera le monde a faim pour
cette séquence merci à tous les deux
merci à jean luc trotignon pour
anticorps philippe brillault de l'ump
maire du chesnay vous restez avec nous
sur le plateau puisque on va parler du
mariage pour tous également puisque vous
étiez et vous êtes toujours l'un des
membres actifs de ce collectif manif
pour tous la loi a été adoptée hier en
lecture solennelle auparavant on fait
une petite pause on va parler culture
l'actualité culturelle du jour